sandrine tu me vois un morceau de piano
je dois bien écoutez comment tu joues
[Musique]
oui
ok ok ça c'est là ça c'est la partie
technique ça démontre rien prend plutôt
la partie centrale que je puisse sentir
un peu tes émotions enfin si tu as
quelque chose en plus quand tu joues
m
et oh
le thé pas fait pour le piano
c'est évident
d'ailleurs tant que tu n'as pas joué
d'une étude de chopin doit jamais niveau
cette scène j'ai vécu lorsque j'avais 17
ans
comme sa sortie nul par un professeur de
musique me dis que le piano ce n'est pas
fait pour moi
ça faisait plus de treize ans que je
faisais du piano
j'ai commencé le piano au conservatoire
à quatre ans c'est donc à peu près toute
ma vie qu'il remettait en question en
quelques secondes
charles aznavour a dit que la critique
s'il est constructive peut vraiment
aider un artiste en revanche celle est
gratuite c'est un crime
on lui a dit qu'il était trop petit trop
laid que ces chansons ne valait rien
qu'il n'arriverait jamais
pourtant il a marqué l'histoire de la
chanson française
walt disney s'est fait virer parce qu'il
manquait de créativité
et c'est suite à cet échec qu'il créa
son premier studio d'animation
je crois qu'on peut tous identifiés à ce
genre de situation on a un rêve un
objectif et tout à coup un obstacles se
dressent sur notre chemin
ça peut être une parole un échec
quelque chose qui nous fait douter
peut-être même abandonné
alors comment passer au travers de ses
difficultés et même plus comment les
transformer en opportunité
eh bien je me suis posé ces questions
j'ai repensé au moins mon professeur de
musique au mot de tant d'autres qui ont
croisé mon chemin aux nombreux échecs
que j'ai dû surmonter et je me suis
demandé comment j'avais fait pour passer
au travers de tout ça et pour aller
encore plus loin
alors non je ne suis pas moines
bouddhistes et je ne détiens pas la
vérité
mais j'aimerais partager avec vous ce
qui a marché pour moi et si je peux
aider ne serait ce qu'une seule personne
alors j'en serai très reconnaissante
donc voilà les quatre clés qui m'ont
aidé à triompher des obstacles et qui
aujourd'hui mais elle a guidé mes choix
répondre avec la bonne attitude
prendre du recul
persévérer pour atteindre ses rêves et
exprimé la gratitude
je vais vous les illustrer l'une après
l'autre
répondre avec la bonne attitude
je pense que l'une des premières choses
qui va influencer tout ce qui va suivre
dans notre vie c'est notre attitude face
aux différentes situations
peu importe notre âge notre statut
social ou notre nationalité nous allons
réagir absolument tous différemment face
aux situations de la ville une même
situation va paraître totalement
dévastatrice pour une personne est tout
à fait surmontable pour une autre c'est
la diversité de chacun différents état
d'esprit différentes manières de réagir
différentes penser
c'est ce qui fait selon moi que
certaines personnes sont plus heureuses
que d'autres peu importe sa situation
amoureuse familiale ou financière
avant de m'expatrier aux états unis j'ai
eu la chance de vivre une retraite en
écosse
l'homme qui anime et nos séances de
méditation quotidienne se faisait
appeler à petit bouddha le bouddha
heureux
ce fameux happy bouddha
m'a transmis une notion qui m'est utile
tous les jours de ma vie
la métaphore des deux poignards
il m'a expliqué que lorsqu'une situation
compliquée se présente à nous c'est
comme si nous recevions un premier
poignard dans le ventre
et ensuite tout dépend de ce qu'on en
fait
soit et malheureusement nous avons tous
déjà fait nous nous plantons nous mêmes
un deuxième poignard et ce deuxième
poignard peut-être le fait de remuer le
négatif encore et encore de porter trop
d'importance à ce premier poignards et
de faire un peu la victime
ou alors nous travaillons pour tenter de
retirer directement ce premier poignard
et cette métaphore peut s'appliquer à
toutes les situations de la vie des plus
insignifiante au plus grave
alors c'est vrai que nous ne partons pas
tous égaux dans cette vie que ce soit
juste par la famille ou le pays dans
lequel nous sommes nés mais alors s'il
ya des choses qu'on ne peut pas
contrôler pourquoi ne pas se concentrer
sur ce qu'on peut influencer
quand j'étais au panama pour un voyage
humanitaire
j'étais dans la jungle dans une
communauté indigène et j'ai vu deux
hommes avec la même famille la même
situation les mêmes chances et les mêmes
ambitions mais avec de vie totalement
différente
l'un d'entre eux avaient voyagé avait
appris des langues avaient fait des
études
l'autre était resté là par peur
d'échouer pendant que sa situation ne
lui permettrai jamais de réussir
leur attitude face à la vie a été
totalement différente et leur vie
également
c'est pour ça que je pense que notre
attitude peut influencer toute notre vie
alors la prochaine fois qu'une situation
compliquée se présente à nous
repensons à ce fameux happy bouddha est
plutôt que de se planter un deuxième
poignard essayons de nous enlever le
premier
prendre du recul
je pense que devons chaque situation
il est bien de prendre du recul de se
placer en tant que spectateur ou
spectatrice
et d'analyser la situation d'un point de
vue extérieur
par exemple si l'on reçoit une critique
se demander si cette critique est
gratuite
si c'est le cas prendre conscience que
ce n'est qu'une pensée qu'un point de
vue et que ça n'a peut-être rien à voir
avec la vérité cette prise de conscience
va nous aider à ne pas prendre sur soi
et à laisser passer cette critique
au contraire cette si cette critique est
constructive
alors prendre ce qu'il ya à prendre
travailler sur ce point pour devenir
meilleur
quand le moment de choisir s'il allait
entreprendre des études s'est présentée
à moi ma maîtresse m'a dit que ce
n'était pas fait pour moi
alors c'est vrai que je n'étais pas ce
qu'on pouvait appeler une lumière
mais j'avais les notes j'étais motivé et
je travaillais beaucoup
une camarade de classe qui avait
exactement les mêmes notent que moi se
faisait encouragés par cette même
maîtresse à entreprendre des études
alors que moi le monde dissuader
alors j'ai demandé pourquoi
pourquoi est ce que mon ami qui a les
mêmes notent que moi et des notes très
modeste devrait faire des études et pas
moi
elle m'a répondu parce que je vous
connais je sais qu'elle y arrivera et
pas toi
alors j'ai pris du recul sur la
situation je me suis demandé si ce
qu'elle disait était vrai
j'ai réalisé que ce n'était absolument
pas fondées
et que ce n'était que son point de vue
j'ai donc décidé de ne pas l'écouter et
j'ai entrepris des études
et durant tout mon parcours j'en ai
rencontré d'autres des professeurs qui
ont tenté de me décourager
par exemple un professeur d'anglais a
dit à mes parents qu'il n'avait jamais
vu de toute sa vie d'élève aussi nuls en
anglais que moi et que je n'apprendrai
simplement jamais cette langue
un directeur m'a même fortement
encouragée à laisser tomber mes études
encore une fois j'ai pris du recul je me
suis demandé si ce qu'il disait c'est
vrai j'ai réalisé qu'il ne me
connaissait absolument pas
et que c'était que l'on que leur point
de vue
j'ai donc décidé de ne pas les écouter
et j'ai continué
j'ai obtenu ma maturité j'ai entrepris
des études universitaires en musique
j'ai eu un bachelor en musique un master
en musique
et aujourd'hui je vis aux états unis et
devinez quoi
je parle anglais
comme quoi tout est possible
prends leur parole pour une vérité et ne
pas prendre du recul face à ce qu'il
disait aurait été une erreur monumentale
de ma part toute ma carrière
professionnelle en seraient influencés
et je ne serais pas là où je suis
aujourd'hui
j'aurai beaucoup de regret
mais tout ça n'est pas arrivé en
claquant des doigts
j'ai dû travailler dur et persévérer
persévérer pour atteindre ses rêves
quand on a un rêve ou une envie malgré
les échecs qui sont inévitables il est
important de garder en tête notre
objectif
walt disney l'a dit et fio can't get you
can make up je vous avais bien dit que
je parle anglais
mais malheureusement la bonne attitude
ne suffit pas il ya toujours une part de
travail considérable derrière chaque
réussite
quand j'étais au conservatoire
on m'a surnommé l'intello du solfège
c'est vrai que j'avais beaucoup de
facilité et que j'avais des notes
presque maximal à chaque examen mais ce
que les gens ne savaient pas c'est
qu'avant de devenir cet intello du
solfège j'avais lamentablement échoué
mon premier examen de solfège tout comme
mon frère d'ailleurs
je ne comprenais absolument rien et
j'étais vraiment très nul
je pensais que ma carrière musicale
s'arrêtait là malgré que j'avais sept ou
huit ans
je pensais que je ferai plus jamais de
piano
alors ma professeure de piano m'a
orienté vers une personne extraordinaire
une soeurs du couvent de saint maurice
soeur marie elisabeth
elle devait avoir 80 ans mais avait une
énergie incroyable et un savoir
exceptionnelle et elle savait le
transmettre
alors avec mon frère nous avons
travaillé une année ils devront passer
une année entière de travail acharné
chaque jour nous faisons répéter le
solfège en utilisant les techniques de
soeur marie élisabeth chaque semaine nos
passions des heures avec elle a
travaillé le solfège et elle était
extrêmement sévère elle ne rigolait pas
elle nous avait prévenus
j'ai pas de temps à perdre si vous ne
travaillez pas ses dehors
avec mon frère en tremble et de terreur
c'était très dur
et tout ce travail en plus de l'école de
nos devoirs de notre pratique
quotidienne de notre instrument de nos
cours d'instrument de nos cours de
solfège et de nos loisirs
mais une année après je me suis
représenté à cet examen de solfège
et j'ai eu 5 9 sur six
on m'a vu enlever un dixième pour la
propreté
alors ça en a valu la peine depuis ce
jour j'étais devenu l'intello du solfège
tout me paraissait simple facile et
évident
mais cette histoire m'a appris une chose
c'est qu'un échec ce n'est qu'une
opportunité pour devenir meilleurs et
qu'en persévérant on ne peut qu réussir
exprimé de la gratitude
si nous arrivons là où nous en sommes
aujourd'hui dans la vie
ce n'est pas à cause mais grâce à tout
ce qui nous est arrivé et à tous les
obstacles qui se sont dressés sur notre
chemin alors il faut en être
reconnaissant
les émotions négatives comme la
tristesse la colère la rancune les
regrets nous empêchent d'avancer et
d'être heureux
alors que la gratitude apaise ses
blessures et fait que nous en sommes
fiers
je pense que la gratitude c'est une
manière de vivre heureux avec tous nos
repas c'est quel qu'il soit
je pense aussi que la gratitude est une
des solutions pour enlever ce premier
poignardant nous parler à petit bouddha
ces quatre clés que je vous ai partagé
ce soir mon ouverte de nombreuses portes
je pense qu'elles sont accessibles à
toutes et à tous
quels que soient les obstacles auxquels
vous êtes confrontés
quatre clés ça pourrait très bien marché
pour vous aussi
alors je vous le dis aujourd'hui
j'aimerais remercier ce professeur de
musique qui m'a dit que le piano ce
n'était pas fait pour moi
j'ai su laisser de côté la partie
gratuite de son commentaire et prendre
la partie constructive
j'ai donc joué une étude de chopin et
j'ai poussé mon niveau de piano encore
plus loin
[Musique]
à
une année après le commentaire de mon
professeur de musique cette étude de
chopin a été au programme de mon dernier
examen de piano au conservatoire
et cette vidéo m'a obtenu une bourse
pour aller étudier aux états unis
alors j'aimerais sincèrement remercier
ce professeur de musique et j'aimerais
dire merci à toutes les personnes qui se
sont dressés sur mon chemin à tous les
échecs et à tous les obstacles que j'ai
dû surmonter car ils m'ont permis de
devenir meilleurs et d'être la personne
que je suis aujourd'hui
alors merci
[Applaudissements]